Now one last technique that we will discuss that can be helpful in reducing
stress and in turn have positive effects on physical and psychological health
is meditation. Meditation involves the practice of sitting quietly and clearing
one's mind by concentrating on the present moment. Now this may sound easy to
do but it's actually quite difficult. Mindfulness is one technique for focusing
on present. That is, being in the moment. So, mindfulness meditation is the act
of meditating while being aware of the present moment. And in the present
moment, concentrating only on breathing or in some cases, you may concentrate
on a particular saying or thought. Mindfulness meditation has been shown to
have a positive effect on both physiological and psychological well being. For
example, reducing pain, depression and anxiety. Therefore, mindfulness
meditation is an important technique or tool that can be used to combat the
negative reactions to stress. I encourage you to go to YouTube and look up some
mindfulness meditation practices and then try them. And incorporate these into
your daily activities so you can have a powerful tool for combating negative
psychological and physiological effects of stress.